evil in their hearts use our senators to
bring peace and unity to our world may
they permit godliness to make them bold
as lions give them a clearer vision of
your desires for our nation remind them
that they borrow their heartbeats from
you each day provide them with such
humility hope and courage that they will
do your will Lord grant that this
impeachment trial will make our nation
stronger wiser and better we pray in
your strong name amen please join me in
reciting the pledge of allegiance to the
flag
please be seated if there is no
objection the journal of proceedings of
the trial are approved to date without
objection so ordered
the sergeant in arms will make the
proclamation hear ye hear ye hear ye all
persons are commanded to keep silent on
pain of imprisonment while the Senate of
the United States is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the House of
Representatives against Donald John
Trump President of the United States as
Chief Justice the majority leader is
recognized we expect several hours
obsession' today with probably one quick
break in the middle thank you pursuant
to the provisions of Senate resolution
483 the counsel for the president have
15 hours and 33 minutes remaining to
make the presentation of their case
though will not be possible to use the
remainder of that time before the end of
the day the Senate will now hear you
Thank You mr. Chief Justice members of
the Senate just to give you a very quick
brief overview of today we do not intend
to use much of that time today mr. chief
justice we intend to be our goal is to
be finished by dinnertime and well
before we'll have three presentations
first will be Pat Philbin deputy White
House Counsel then Jay Sekulow
will give a presentation we'll take a
break if that's okay with you mr. leader
and then after that I'll finish with a
presentation so that's our goal for the
day and with that I'll turn it over to
Pat Philbin
mr. Chief Justice members of the Senate
Majority Leader McConnell Minority
Leader Schumer I'd like to start today
by making a couple of observations
related to the abuse of power charged in
the first article of impeachment and I
wouldn't presume to elaborate on
professor Dershowitz his presentation
from yesterday evening which I thought
was complete and compelling but I wanted
to just add a couple of very specific
points in support of the exposition of
the Constitution and the impeachment
clause that he set out and it begins
from a focus on the point in the debate
about the impeachment clause at the
Constitutional Convention where
maladministration was offered by George
Mason as a grounds for impeachment and
James Madison responded that that was a
bad idea and he said so vague a term
will be equivalent to a tenure during
the pleasure of the Senate and that
evinced a deep-seated concern that
Madison had and it's part of the whole
design of our Constitution for ways that
can lead to exercises of arbitrary power
the Constitution was designed to put
limits and checks on all forms of
government power obviously one of the
great mechanisms for that is the
separation of powers the structural
separation of powers in our Constitution
but it also comes from defining and
limiting powers and responsibilities and
a concern that vague terms vague
standards are themselves an opportunity
for the expansion of power and the
exercise of arbitrary power and we see
that throughout the Constitution and in
the impeachment Clause as well and this
is why as governor Morris argued in
discussing the impeachment clause that
only few offenses he said few offenses
ought to be impeachable
and the cases ought to be enumerated and
defined and that's why we see in the
debate that the Constitution there was a
many terms had been included in earlier
drafts when it was narrowed down to
treason and bribery and there was a
suggestion to include maladministration
which had been a ground for impeachment
in English practice the framers rejected
it because it was too vague it was too
expansive it would allow for arbitrary
exercises of power and we see throughout
the Constitution in terms that relate
and fit in with the impeachment Clause
the same concern one is in the
definition of treason the framers were
very concerned that the English practice
of having a vague concept of treason
that was malleable and could be changed
even after the facts to define new
concepts of treason was dangerous it was
one of the things that they wanted to
reject from the English system so they
defined in the Constitution very
specifically what constituted treason
and how it had to be proved and then
that term was incorporated into the
impeachment clause similarly in the
rejection of maladministration which had
been an impeachable offense in england
the framers rejected that because it was
vague a vague standard something that's
too changeable that can be redefined can
be malleable after the fact allows for
the arbitrary exercise of power and that
would be dangerous to give that power to
the legislature as a power to impeach
the executive and similarly and it
relates again to the impeachment clause
one of the greatest dangers from having
changeable standards that existed in the
English system was bills of attainder
undergo of attainder the Parliament
could pass a specific law saying that a
specific person had done something
unlawful they were being attainted even
though it wasn't unlawful before that
and the framers rejected that entire
concept in article 1 section 9 they
eliminated both bills of attainder and
all ex post facto laws for criminal
penalty's at the federal level and they
also included a provision to prohibit
States from using bills of attainder now
in the English system there was a
relationship to some extent between
impeachment and bills of attainder
because both were tools of the
Parliament to get at officials in the
government you could impeach them for an
established offence or you could pass of
a bill of attainder and it was because
the definition of impeachment was being
narrowed the George Mason at the debate
suggested he pointed out in the English
system there's a bill of attainder it's
been a great useful tool for the
government but we're eliminating that
and now we're getting a narrow
definition of impeachment we ought to
expand it to include maladministration
and Madison said no one the framers
agreed we have to have enumerated and
defined offenses not a vague concept not
something that can be blurry and
interpreted after the fact and it could
be used essentially to make policy
differences or other differences like
that the subject of impeachment all the
steps that the framers took in the way
they approached the impeachment clause
were in terms of narrowing restricting
constraining and numerating offenses and
not a vague and malleable approach as
there had been in the English system and
I think the minority views of Republican
members of the House Judiciary Committee
at the time of the Nixon impeachment
inquiry summed this up and reflected it
well because they explained and I'm
quoting from the minority views in the
report the whole tenor of the framers
discussions the whole purpose of their
many careful departures from English
impeachment practice was in the
direction of limits and of standards an
impeachment power exercised without
extrinsic and objective standards would
be tantamount to the use of bills of
attainder and ex post facto laws which
are expressly forbidden by the
Constitution and are contrary to the
American spirit of justice and what we
see in the house managers charges
and their definition of abuse of power
is exactly antithetical to the framers
approach because their very premise for
their abuse of power charge is that it
is entirely based on subjective motive
not objective standards not predefined
offenses but the president can do
something that is perfectly lawful
perfectly within his authority but if
the real reason as professor Dershowitz
pointed out that's the language from
their report the reason in the
president's mind is something that they
ferret out and decide is wrong
that becomes impeachable and that's
exactly malleable and it's something
that I think a telling factor that
reflects how malleable it is and how
dangerous it is is in the House
Judiciary Committee's report because
after they define their concept of abuse
of power and they say that it involves
you're exercising government power for
personal interest and not the national
interest and it depends on your
subjective motives they realize that
that's infinitely malleable there's not
really a clear standard there and it's
violating a fundamental premise of the
American system of justice that you have
to have notice of what is wrong you have
to have notice of an offense and this is
something that professor Dershowitz
pointed out last night there has to be a
defined offense in advance and the way
they try to resolve this is to say well
in addition to our definition high
crimes and misdemeanors involve conduct
that is recognizably wrong to a
reasonable person and that's their kind
of add-on to deal with the fact that
they have an unconstitutionally vague
standard they don't have a standard that
really defines a specific offense they
don't have a standard that really
defines in coherent terms that are going
to be identifiable what the offenses are
so they just add on and it's got to be
recognizably wrong and they say that
they're doing this to resolve attention
they call it within the Constitution
because they point out and this is
quoting from the report the structure of
the Constitution including its
prohibition on bills of attainder and
the ex post facto clause implies that
impeachable offenses should not come as
a surprise that's exactly what professor
Dershowitz pointed out and everything
about the terms of the Constitution
speaking of an offense and a conviction
that it's a crime should be tried by
jury except impeachments they all talk
about impeachment in those criminal
offense terms but the tension here isn't
within the Constitution it's between the
house managers definition which lacks
any coherent definition of an offense
that would catch people by surprise and
the Constitution that's the tension that
they're trying to resolve is between
their malleable standards that actually
states no clear offense and the
Constitution and the principles of
justice embodied in the Constitution
that requires some clear offense so he
wanted to point that out in relation to
the standards for impeachable offenses
because it's another piece of the
constitutional puzzle that fits in with
the exposition to professor Dershowitz
set out and it also shows an inherent
flaw in the house managers theory of
abuse of power regardless of whether or
not one accepts the view that an
impeachable offense has to be a crime
and defined crime there is still the
flaw in their definition of abuse of
power that it is so malleable
based on purely subjective standards
that it does not provide any cognizable
notice of an offense it is so malleable
it in effect recreates the offense of
maladministration that the framers
expressly rejected as professor
Dershowitz explained the second point
that I wanted to make is that how do we
tell under the house managers standard
what an illicit motive is when there's
an illicit motive how are we supposed to
get the proof
of what's inside the president said
because of course motive is inherently
difficult to prove where you're talking
about as they've conceded they're
talking about perfectly lawful actions
on their face within the constitutional
authority of the president but they want
to make it in P chable if it's just the
wrong idea inside the president's head
and they explained in the House
Judiciary Committee report that the way
will tell if the president had the wrong
motive is we'll compare what he did to
what staffers in the executive branch
said he ought to do so they say quote
that the president quote disregarded
United States foreign policy towards
Ukraine and quote and that he ignored
quote unquote official policy that he
had been briefed on and that he quote
ignored defied and confounded every
agency within the executive branch end
quote
that is not a constitutionally coherent
statement the president cannot defy
agencies within the executive branch
article 2 section 1 of the Constitution
vests all of the executive power in a
President of the United States he alone
is an entire branch of government
he sets policy for the executive branch
he's given vast power and of course
within limits set by laws passed by
Congress and within limits set by
spending priorities and spending laws
passed by Congress he within those
constraints sets the policies of the
government and in areas of Foreign
Affairs military affairs national
security which is what we're dealing
with in this case Foreign Affairs head
of state communications he has vast
powers as professor Dershowitz explained
for over two centuries the president has
been regarded as the sole organ of the
nation and foreign affairs so the idea
that we're going to find out when the
president had the wrong subjective
motives by comparing
he did to the recommendations of some
interagency consensus among staffers is
fundamentally anti-constitutional it
inverts the constitutional structure and
it's also fundamentally anti-democratic
because our system is rather unique in
the amount of power that it gives to the
president the executive here is more
much more power than Ana parliamentary
system but part of the reason that the
president can have that power is that he
is directly democratically accountable
to the people there is an election every
four years to ensure that the president
stays democratically accountable to the
people but those staffers in these
supposed interagency who have their
meetings and make recommendations to the
president are not accountable to the
people there is no democratic legitimacy
or accountability to their decisions or
recommendations and that is why it is
the president as head of the executive
branch who has the authority to actually
set policies and make determinations
regardless of what the staffers may
recommend they are there to provide
information and recommendations not to
set policy so the idea that we're going
to start impeaching presidents by
deciding that they have illicit motives
if we can show that they disagree with
some interagency consensus it's
fundamentally contrary to the
Constitution and fundamentally
anti-democratic so those were the two
observations I wanted to add to
supplement specific points on professor
Dershowitz his comments from last night
now I want to shift gears and respond to
a couple of points that the house
managers have brought up that are really
a completely extraneous to this
proceeding they involve matters that are
not charged in the articles of
impeachment they do not direct really
direct Berlet excuse me relate directly
to the president for his actions but
they are accusations that were brought
up somewhat recklessly in any event
and we cannot close without some
response to them and the first has to do
with the idea that somehow the White
House and and White House lawyers were
involved in some sort of cover-up
related to the transcript of the July
25th call because it was stored on a
highly classified system so let me start
with that the house managers made this
accusation there was something nefarious
going on but let's see what the
witnesses actually had to say
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander bin Minh
and remember Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh
is the person who was listening in on a
call and who raised a concern the only
person who went and raised a concern
with NSC lawyers that he thought he
thought there was something improper
something wrong with the call even
though he later conceded under
cross-examination it was really a policy
concern but he thought there was
something wrong and he had to say that
he did not think he said so I do not
think there was malicious intent or
anything of that nature to cover
anything up he's the one who went and
talked to the lawyers he's the one whose
complaint spurred the idea that wait
there might be something that's really
sensitive here we should make sure that
this is not going to leak he thought
there was nothing covering it up his
boss senior director Tim Morrison had
similar testimony so this your knowledge
there's no malicious intent in moving
the transcript to the compartment and
server correct and the idea that there
was some sort of cover-up is further
destroyed by the simple fact that
everyone who is part of their jobs
needed access to that transcript still
had access to it including
lieutenant-colonel VIN Minh right so the
person who raises a complaint still has
access to the transcript the entire time
and this is the way mr. Morrison's
testimony explained that and even on the
codeword server you had access to it yes
so at no point in time during the course
your official duties were you where you
denied access to this information
correct correct
and to your knowledge anybody on the NSC
staff that needed access to the
transcript for their official duties
always was able to access it correct
people that had a need-to-know and I
need to access it once it was moved to
the compartment system yes
okay now as mr. Morrison testified he'd
recommended restricting access to the
transcript not because he had any
concern that there was anything improper
or illegal but he was concerned about a
potential leak and as he put it how that
quote would play out in Washington's
polarized environment end quote and
would quote affect the bipartisan
support our Ukrainian partners currently
experience in Congress and he was right
to be concerned potentially about leaks
because the Trump administration has
fast faced national security leaks at an
alarming rate
Lieutenant Colonel bin Minh himself said
that concerns about leaks seemed
justified and it was not unusual that
something would be put in a more
restricted circulation now what else is
in the record evidence Mr Morrison
explained his understanding of how the
transcript ended up on that server I
spoke with the NSC executive Secretariat
staff asked them why and they did their
research and they inform me it had been
moved to the higher classification
system at the direction of John
Eisenberg whom I then asked why I mean
that's that was the judgment he made
that's not necessarily mind a question
but I didn't understand it and he
essentially told me I gave no such
direction he did his own inquiry and he
represented back to me that it was his
understanding was it was a kind of
administrative error that when he also
gave direction to restrict access the
executive secretary of staff understood
that as a apprehension that there was
something in the content of the men con
that could not exist on the lower
education system so this your knowledge
there's no malicious intent in moving
the transcript to the compartment and
server correct everyone who knew
something about it and who testified
agreed there was no malicious intent the
call was still available to everyone who
needed it as part of their job and it
certainly wasn't covered up for deep
sixed in some way the president
Declassified it and made it public so
why were even here talking about these
accusations about a cover-up when it's a
transcript that was preserved and made
public is somewhat absurd now the other
point I'd like to turn to another
accusation from the house managers is
that the whistleblower complaint when
the whistleblower complaint was not
forwarded to Congress they've said that
lawyers at the Department of Justice
this time they accuse OLC the office of
legal counsel of providing a bogus
opinion for why the Director of National
Intelligence did not have to advance the
whistleblowers complaint to Congress and
manager Jeffries said that OLC opined
quote without any reasonable basis that
the Acting DNI did not have to turn over
the complaint to Congress end quote
and the way he portrayed this now
there's a statute that says if the
Inspector General of the intelligence
community finds a matter of urgent
concern it must meet it must be
forwarded to Congress and manager
Jeffries portrayed this as if the only
thing to decide was were these claims
urgent he said quote what could be more
urgent than a sitting president's trying
to cheat in an American election by
soliciting foreign interference that's
not the only question the statute
doesn't just say if it's urgent
you have to forward it it talks about
urgent concern as a defined term now if
the house managers want to come and cast
accusations that the political and
career fish
at the office of legal counsel which we
all know is a very respected office of
the Department of Justice provides
opinions for the executive branch on
what governing law is they should come
backed up with analysis so let's look at
what the law actually says and I think
we have the slide of that urgent concern
is defined as a serious or flagrant
problem abuse violation of law relating
to the funding administration or
operation of an intelligence activity
within the responsibilities and
authority of the Director of National
Intelligence involving classified
information so the office of legal
counsel was consulted by the general
counsel at the DA's office and they
looked at this definition and they did
an analysis and they determined that the
alleged misconduct is not an urgent
concern within the meaning of the
statute because they're not just talking
about do we think it's urgent do we
think it's important know they're
analyzing the law and they looked at the
terms of the statute the alleged
misconduct is not an urgent concern
within the meaning of the statute
because it does not concern the funding
administration or operation of an
intelligence activity under the
authority of the DNI remember what we're
talking about here is a head of state
communication between the President of
the United States and another head of
state this isn't some CIA operation
overseas this isn't the NSA doing
something this isn't any intelligence
activity going on within the
intelligence community under the
supervision of the DNI it's the head of
the executive branch exercising his
constitutional authority engaging in
foreign relations with a foreign head of
state
so in reaching that conclusion the
office of legal counsel looked at the
statute case law the legislative history
and it concluded that this phrase origin
concern includes matters relating to it
intelligence activities subject to the
DNI supervision but it does not include
allegations of wrongdoing arising
outside of any intelligence activity for
outside the intelligence community
itself and that makes sense
this statute was meant to provide for an
ability of the Inspector General of the
intelligence community overseeing the
activities of the intelligence community
to receive reports about what was going
on at intelligence agencies those that
are members of the intelligence
community if there was fraud waste abuse
something unlawful in those activities
it was not meant to create an Inspector
General of the presidency an inspector
general of the Oval Office to purport to
determine whether the president in
exercising his constitutional
authorities had done something that
should be reported this law is narrow
and it does not cover every alleged
violation of law will see explained or
other abuse that comes to the attention
of a member of the intelligence
community just because you're in the
intelligence community happen to see
something else doesn't make this law
apply and the law does not make the
inspector general for the intelligence
community responsible for investigating
and reporting on allegations that do not
involve intelligence activities or the
intelligence community now nonetheless
the president of course released the
July 25th call transcript and it was
also not the end of the matter
that the whistleblower complaints in the
DNI the IC IGS letter were not sent
directly to Congress because OLC
explained that if the complaint does not
involve an urgent concern but if there's
anything else there that you want to
have checked out the appropriate action
is to refer the matter to the Department
of Justice and that's what the DA's
office did they sent the IC IGS letter
with the
to the Department of Justice and the
Department of Justice looked at it and
this was all made public some time ago
the Department of Justice examined the
exact allegations of the whistleblower
and the exact framing and concern raised
by the Inspector General which had to do
with a potential of perhaps a campaign
finance law of violation DOJ looked at
it looked at the statutes analyzed it
and determined there wasn't a violation
and it closed the matter and it
announced that months ago all right when
something gets sent over to the
Department of Justice to examine you
can't call that a cover-up everything
here was done correctly the lawyers
analyzed the law the complaint was sent
to the appropriate person for review it
was not within the statute that required
transmission to Congress and everything
was handled entirely properly so again
actually extraneous to the matters
before you there's nothing about this
these two points in the articles of
impeachment but it merits a response
when reckless allegations are made
against those at the White House and at
the Department of Justice and with that
mr. Chief Justice all yield back my time
to mr. Sekulow
Thank You mr. chief justice which
already legal McConnell Democratic
leader Schumer house managers members of
the Senate what we are involved in here
as we conclude is perhaps the most
solemn of duties under our
constitutional framework the trial of
the leader of the free world and the
duly elected president of the United
States it is not a game of leaks and
unsourced manuscripts that's politics
unfortunately and Hamilton put
impeachment in the hands of this body
the Senate precisely and specifically to
be above that fray this is the greatest
deliberative body on earth in our
presentation so far you've now heard
from legal scholars from a variety of
schools of thought from a variety of
political backgrounds but they do have a
common theme with a dire warning danger
danger danger to lower the bar of
impeachment based on these articles of
impeachment would impact the functioning
of our constitutional republic and the
framework of that Constitution for
generations I asked you to put yourself
and reporting Mr ships manager shifts
statement his father made about putting
yourself in the shoes of someone else
and I I said I'd like you to put your
shoes yourself in the shoes of the
president and I think it's important as
we conclude too
that were minded of that fact the
President of the United States before he
was the president was under an
investigation it was called crossfire
hurricane who was investigation led by
the FBI the Federal Bureau of
Investigation James Comey eventually
told the president a little bit about
the investigation and referenced the
steel dossier James Comey the Drude then
director of the FBI said it was
salacious and unverified so salacious
and unverified that they used it as a
basis to obtain FISA warrants members
managers here managers at this table
right here said that any discussions on
the abuse from the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Act utilized to get the
FISA warrants from the court or
conspiracy theories I told you at the
very beginning I asked do you put
yourself in the shoes of not just this
president of any president that would
have been under this type of attack by
the warrants issued on people affiliated
with his campaign American citizens
affiliated the people of Hippias
campaign citizens of the United States
being surveilled pursuant to an order
that is now been acknowledged by the
very court that issued the order that it
was based on a fraudulent presentation
in fact evidence specifically changed
changed by the very FBI lawyer who was
in charge of this
change to such an extent that the
foreign surveillance intelligence court
as I said earlier not repeated again
issued two orders saying that when this
agent this lawyer made these
misrepresentations to the National
Security Division they also made a
misrepresentation to a federal court the
federal court the foreign surveillance
court a court where there are no defense
witnesses a court where there are is no
cross-examination it's a court based on
trust that trust was violated and then
the director of the Federal Bureau of
Investigation James Comey decides he
will leak a memo a big conversation he
had with the President of the United
States and he is leaking the memo for a
purpose he said to obtain the
appointment of a special counsel and lo
and behold a special counsel was
appointed and it just so happens that
that FBI agent lawyer who committed the
fraud on the FISA Court became a lawyer
from the Muller investigation only to be
removed because of political animus and
bias found by the inspector general then
we have a Special Counsel investigation
Lisa page agent Sturrock I'm not going
to go into the details you know them
they're not in controversy they're
uncontroverted the facts are clear but
does it bother your sense of justice
even a little bit even a little bit that
bob mower
allowed the evidence on the phones of
those agents to be wiped clean while
there was an investigation going on by
the inspector general now if you did it
if you did it managership if you didn't
manager Jeffries if I did that destroyed
evidence if anyone in this chamber did
this we'd be in serious trouble they're
serious trouble as they get fired
Bob Muller's explanation for it is I
don't know what happened I don't know
what happened I can't recall the
conversations you can't view this case
in a vacuum you are being asked and I
say this with the utmost respect you are
being asked to remove an elected duly
elected president of the United States
this isn't some we had references to law
school exams I love the fact that I
thought that was were great analysis
yesterday and I appreciate all that but
I want to focus today or my section on
what you're being asked to do you are
being asked to remove a duly elected
president of the United States and
you're being asked to do it in an
election year in an election year there
are some of you in this chamber right
now that would rather be someplace else
and that's why we'll be brief I
understand you'd rather be someplace
else why would you rather be someplace
else because you're running for
president the nomination of your party I
get it
but this is a serious deliberative
situation you're being asked to remove a
duly elected president the United States
that's what the articles impeachment
call for removal
so we had a special counsel and we got
the report and just for a moment putting
yourself in the shoes of this president
or any president that would be under
this situation you're number four at the
Department of Justice his wife is
working for the firm that's doing the
opposition research on him and is
communicating with the foreign former
spy
Christopher Steele to put together the
dossier and it's being handled by
Christopher Steele through Nelly or to
her husband then the fourth ranking
member at the Department of Justice
Bruce or and all of this is going on and
he doesn't want to tell and he's
testified to this he doesn't want to
tell everybody what he's doing because
he's afraid he might have to stop might
have to stop how did this happen
this is the Federal Bureau of
Investigation and then we asked why is
the president concerned about advice
he's being given put yourself in his
shoes put yourself in his shoes we've
given you and our approach has been to
give an overview and to be very specific
to remove a duly elected president which
is what you're being asked to do for in
essentially policy disagreements to her
a lot about policy although the one that
I still I it still troubles me and I'm
on this idea that the president it was
sent by several demanders is only doing
these things for himself understanding
what is going on in the world today as
we're here they raised it by the way I'm
not I'm not trying to be disrespectful
I'm they raised it this president is
only doing things for himself while the
leaders of opposing parties by the way
at the highest level
to obtain peace in the Middle East to
say you're only doing that for yourself
I think the irony of that that those
statements were made while all of that
was going on and and other acts at this
body's past submitted bipartisan to help
the American people policy differences
those policy difference cannot be
utilized to destroy the separation of
powers house manager spoke for I know
we've had disagreements on the time it
was 21 hours of 23 hours they spoke
during their time a lot of time most of
it attacking the president policy
decisions made it like what they heard
they didn't like there was a pause on
foreign aid I laid out before that there
was pauses on all kinds of foreign aid
it's not the first president to do it
but the one thing I am still trying to
understand from the managers perspective
and maybe it's not fair to ask the
managers because you're not the you know
the leader of the of the house but
remember the whole idea that this was a
dire national security threat a danger
to our nation we had to get this over
here right away
it had to be done before Christmas it
was so important was so significant the
country was in such jeopardy the
Jeopardy was so serious that it had to
be done immediately let's hold on to the
articles of impeachment for a month to
see if this house could force the Senate
to adopt rules that they wanted which is
not the way the Constitution is set up
but it was such a dire emergency it was
so critical for our nation's national
interest that we could hold them for 33
days Danger Danger Danger that's
politics
as I said you're being called upon to to
remove the duly elected president of the
United States that's what these articles
of impeachment call for they never
really answered the question of why they
thought there were such a national
emergency maybe they will
during questions I don't know there was
such a national emergency they never did
explain why it was that they waited they
certainly didn't wait to have the
proceedings as my colleagues have laid
out I mean those proceedings it moved in
record time
I suspect that we've been here more than
the the house actually considered the
actual articles of impeachment is that
the way the Constitution is supposed to
work is that the design of the
Constitution
and then their question of course came
up and and yesterday on the whole
situation with Purisima and the Biden's
and that whole issue and my colleagues
went through that a great deal and I'm
not going to do that but do we have a
like are we in a situation we used to
call this in free speech cases like a a
free speech zone you could have your
free speech activities over here you
can't have them over there do we have
like a a Biden free zone and what was
that what this was that there was it's
it's a you mentioned someone or you're
concerned about a company and it's now
off limits you can impeach the president
the United States for asking a question
I think we significantly showed the
question I'm not going to go through a
detail by detail analysis of the facts
but there are some that we just have to
go through you heard a lot of new facts
yesterday in our presentation on
Saturday what we were pointing to is a
very quick overview and then yesterday
we spent the day and we appreciate
everybody's patience on that going
through the facts they showed you this
but they didn't show you that the facts
are important though the applause facts
have legal ramifications legal
ramifications impact the decisions you
make so I don't take facts lightly and I
certainly don't take the constitutional
mandate it's lightly and we can't the
facts we demonstrated yesterday and on
briefly on Saturday demonstrate that
there was in fact a proper governmental
interest in the questions that the
president asked and the issues that the
president raised on that phone call a
phone call now let's again put your
shoes in the put your feet in the shoes
of the president put yourself in the
president's position do you think he
thought when he was on the call it was
him and president Solinsky he was
talking to and that was it
or it was as sometimes I heard one
commentator said it was people listening
in on the call the president and 3,000
of his closest friends let's be
realistic the president united states
knew when he was on that call there were
a lot of people listening from our side
and from their side so he knew what he
was saying he said it we released a
transcript of it the facts on the call
that have been kind of the focus of all
of this really focused on foreign policy
initiatives both in Ukraine and around
the globe they talked about other
countries and other countries the
president has been very concerned about
other countries carrying some of the
financial load here not just the United
States that's a legitimate position for
a president to take if you disagree with
it you have the right to do that but he
is the president as my colleague deputy
white House Counsel Feldman just said
that's the executive branch prerogative
that is their constitutional appropriate
role so the call is well documented
there were lots of people on the call
the person that would be on the other
end of the quid pro quo if it existed
would have been president Solinsky but
president Solinsky and we already laid
out the other officials from Ukraine
have repeatedly said there was no
pressure it was a good call they didn't
even know there was a pause in the aid
all of that is well documented I'm not
going to go through each and every one
of those facts we did that over the last
several days president solinsky's senior
advisor under a year mack was asked if
he ever felt there was a connection
between military aid in the request for
investigations and he was
adamant that we never had that feeling
and we did not have the feeling that
this Aid was connected to any one
specific issue this is coming from the
people who were receiving the aid so we
talked about this whole quid pro quo and
that was a big issue that's how this
actually before it became a impeachment
proceeding there was as the proceedings
were beginning in house permanent Select
Committee on Intelligence under
chairmanships role there was all these
discussions is it a quid pro quo was it
was it extortion was it bribery what was
it and we are clear in our position that
there was no quid pro quo but then
yesterday my co-counsel Professor Alan
Dershowitz explained last night that
these articles must be rejected he's
talking about from a constitutional
framework even if there was a quid pro
quo which we have clearly established
there was not and this is what he said
and I'm going to quote it verbatim the
claim that foreign policy decisions can
be deemed abuses of power based on
subjective opinions about mixed were
sole motives that the president was
interested only in helping himself
demonstrate the dangers of employing the
vague subjective and politically
malleable phrase abuse of power as a
constitutionally permissible criteria
for the removal of a president he went
on to say now it follows from this that
if a president any president were to
have done what The Times reported about
the content of John Bolton's manuscript
that would not constitute an impeachable
offense I'm quoting exactly from
Professor Durst which he says let me
repeat it nothing in the Bolton
revelations even if true even if true
would rise to the level
abuse of power or an impeachable offense
that is clear from history that is clear
from the language of the Constitution
you cannot turn conduct that is not
impeachable into impeachable conduct
simply by using words like quid pro quo
and personal benefit it is inconceivable
that the framers would have intended so
so politically loaded and promiscuously
deployed a term as abuse of power to be
weaponized again professor Dershowitz as
a toll of a tool of impeachment it is
precisely the kind of vague open-ended
and subjective term the founders and the
framers feared and rejected now to be
specific
you cannot impeach a president on an
unsourced allegation but what professor
dirty wits are saying even if everything
in there was true it constitutionally
doesn't rise to that level but I want to
be clear on this because there's a lot
of speculation out there with regard to
what john bolton has said which
reference a number of individuals we'll
start with the president here's what the
president said in response to that New
York Times piece I never told John
Bolton that the eight Ukraine was tied
to investigations into Democrats
including the Biden's in fact he never
complained about this at the time of his
very public termination if john bolton
said this it was only to sell a book the
department of justice
while the department of justice has not
reviewed mr. Bolton's manuscript the New
York Times account of his conversation
grossly mischaracterizes what Attorney
General bar and Bolton discussed there
was no discussion of personal favors
were undue influence on investigations
nor did the Attorney General state that
the president's conversations with
foreign leaders were improper the vice
president's chief of staff issued a
statement in every conversation with the
President and the Vice President in
preparation for our trip to
and remember that was the trip that was
being planned for the meeting with
president Solinsky the president
consistent consistently expressed his
frustration that the United States was
bearing the lion's share of
responsibility for H Ukraine and that
European nations weren't doing their
part the president also expressed
concerns about corruption in Ukraine and
at no time did I hear him tie Ukraine
aid to investigations into the Biden
family or burries mom that was the
response
responding to an unpublished manuscript
that maybe some reporters have an idea
of maybe what it says I mean that's what
I mean that's what the evidence if you
want to call that evidence I don't know
what you'd call that I call it an
admissible but that's what it is to
argue that the president is not acting
in our national interest and is
violating his oath of office which the
managers have put forward is wrong based
on the facts and a the way the
Constitution is designed and when you
look at the fullness of the record of
their witnesses their witnesses the
witnesses statements the transcripts
there's one thing that emerges there is
no violation of law there's no violation
of the Constitution there is a
disagreement on policy decisions most of
those that spoke at your hearings did
not like the president's policy that's
why we have elections that's what policy
differentials and differences are
discussed but to have have a removal of
a duly elected president based on a
policy disagreement that is not what the
framers intended and if you lower the
bar that way danger danger
danger because the next president for
the one after that he or she will be
held to that same standard I hope not I
pray not that that's not what happens
not just for the sake of of my client
but for the Constitution you know
professor Dershowitz gave a list of
presidents from Washington to where we
are today who under that standard that
they are proposing could be subject to
abuse of power or obstruction of
Congress look we know that what this is
is not about a president pausing aid to
Ukraine it's really not about a phone
call it's about a lot of attempts on
policy disagreements that are not being
debated here my goodness how much time
how much time has been spent in the
House of Representatives hoping they
were hoping that the Muller probe would
result in me I'm not gonna play I was
thinking about it playing all the clips
from all the commentators the day after
the day after the ball Muller testified
my mother was unable to answer under his
examination basic and fundamental
questions here to correct himself
actually here to correct himself before
the Senate for something he said before
the house so that's what the president's
been living with and then we're here
today arguing about what a phone call to
Ukraine or Ukraine aid being held or a
question about corruption or a question
about corruption that happens to involve
a high public profile figure I mean is
that what this is and is that where we
are and then what do we find out the aid
was released it was released in an
orderly fashion the reform President
President szalinski wins but there was a
question whether his party would take
the Parliament it did they worked late
into the evening with the desire to put
forward reforms so everybody was waiting
including and you heard the testimony
from I will say their witnesses you
heard the testimony everybody was
concerned about Ukraine everybody was
concerned about whether these reforms
could actually take place everybody was
concerned about it
so you hold back didn't affect anything
that was going on in the field we heard
mr. crow worrying about the soldiers I
understand that I appreciate that but
none of that aid was affecting what was
going on on the battlefield right then
or for the next four months because it
was future aid and are we having an
impeachment proceeding because aid came
out three weeks before the end of the
fiscal year or a six-minute phone call
you boil it down that's what this is
it's interesting to me that everybody
saying well the egg was finally released
September 11th only because of of the
committee and the whistleblower who we'd
never seen mr. Philbin dealt with that
in great detail not going to go over
that again but you know the new High
Court the anti-corruption court wasn't
established and did not sit until
September 5th 2019 so while the
president of Ukraine was trying to get
reforms put in place the court that was
going to decide corruption issues was
not set until September 5th I want you
to think about this for a moment - they
needed a high court of corruption for
corruption think about that for a moment
now that's good that they recognized it
but remember when I said the other day
you don't make wave a magic wand and now
Ukraine doesn't have a corruption
problem the High Court of corruption
which they have to have because it's not
just past corruption they're concerned
about ongoing corruption issues and you
could put all of your witnesses back on
the under oath in the next hearings
you'll have when this is all over and
you're going to be back in the house and
we'll be doing this again put them all
back under oath and ask them mr shipp is
there a problem of corruption in Ukraine
and if they get up there and say no
everything is great now hallelujah but I
suspect they're gonna say we're working
really hard on it no I don't believe
them
but this idea that it was just vanished
and now we're back in - everything's
fine it's absurd
mr. Marcin testified that while the
developments were taking place the vice
president also met with President
Solinsky in Warsaw that was the meeting
of September 1st the one by the way
where the vice president's office said
in response to this New York Times see
nobody told him about aide
being held or linked to investigations
are you gonna stop are you going to
allow proceedings on impeachment to go
from a New York Times report about
someone that says what they hear is in a
manuscript is that where we are I don't
think so
I hope not what did marcin say here
firsthand that the new Ukraine
administration was taking concrete steps
to address corruption that's good he
advised the president that the
relationship with szalinski is one that
could be trusted
good presidents and whiskey also agreed
with Vice President pence this is
interesting that the Europeans should be
doing more and related to Vice President
pence conversations he'd been having
with European leaders about getting them
to do more in some the president raised
two issues he was concerned with to get
them addressed now I've already went
over again this is just the closing
moments here of this proceeding of our
portion of this proceeding aid was
withheld or paused put on a pause button
not just for Ukraine Afghanistan South
Korea El Salvador Honduras Guatemala
Lebanon in Pakistan and I'm sure I am
leaving countries out but do you think
the American people are concerned if the
president says you know before we give a
country I don't know five hundred and
fifty million dollars some countries
only four hundred million dollars
we'd like to know what they're doing
with it you're supposed to be the
guardians of the trust here it's the
taxpayers money we're spending
there was a lot of testimony form from
dr. Fiona Hill John Bolton's deputy
here's what she said about aid was being
held this is her testimony there was a
pre put freeze put on all kinds of aid
and assistance because it was in the
process at the time of a awful lot of
reviews of foreign assistance oh you
mean there was a policy within the
administration to review foreign
assistance in how we're doing it because
we spend a lot of money and by the way
I'm not complaining about them I don't
think anybody doesn't want to help but
we do need to know what's going on and
those are valid and important questions
manager crow told you that president the
president's Ukraine policy was not
strong against Russia but ambassador
Jovanovic stated the exact opposite she
said in her deposition that our
countries Ukraine policy under President
Trump actually her words got stronger
than it was under President Obama
so again policy disagreements
disagreements on approach have elections
that's what we do in our republic for
three long days house managers presented
their case by selectively showing parts
of testimony good lawyers show parts of
testimony you don't have to show the
whole thing but other good lawyers show
the rest of the testimony and that's
what we sought to do to give you a
fuller view of what we saw as the
glaring omissions by my colleagues the
house managers the legal issues here are
the constitutional ones and I have been
I think pretty clear over the last week
starting when we had the motions
arguments that my concern about the
constitutional obligations that were
operating under I have been critical of
manager Nadler
executive privilege and other nonsense
we I want you to look at it this way
take out executive privilege First
Amendment free speech and other nonsense
the free exercise of religion and other
nonsense the rights to due process and
other nonsense the rights equal
protection under the laws and other
nonsense you can't start doing that you
would not do that no administration has
done that in fact since the first
administration George Washington they
wanted information he thought it was
privileged he said it was executive
privilege but let's not start calling
constitutional rights other nonsense
lumping them together of course this is
from from a House of Representatives
actually believes the attorney-client
privilege doesn't apply which should
scare every lawyer in Washington DC when
we're more scary to the lawyers will be
for their clients they say that in
writing in letters I don't hide it I
would ask them I don't I'm not going to
it's not my privilege to do that do you
really believe that do you really
believe that the attorney-client
privilege does not apply in a
congressional hearing you really believe
that because then if it doesn't apply
then there is no attorney-client
privilege or is that the attorney-client
privilege and other nonsense Danger
Danger Danger
we believe that article one fails
constitutionally the president has
constitutional authority to engage and
conduct foreign policy and foreign
affairs it is our position legally
president and all times acted with
perfect legal authority inquired of
matters in our national interest and
having received assurances of those
matters continued his policy that his
administration put forward of what
really is unprecedented support for
Ukraine including the delivery of
military aid package that was denied to
the Ukrainians by prior administrations
you know something some of the managers
right here my colleagues at the other
table voted in favor of those jet wanted
javelin anti-tank missiles for Ukraine
some of the members here did not didn't
want to do that voted against that I'm
glad we gave it to him I'm glad we
allowed them to purchase javelins I tell
you I never served in the military I
have tremendous tremendous respect for
the men and women that protect our
freedom each and every day I tremendous
respect for what they are doing and
continue to do but this president
actually allowed the javelins to go some
of you like that idea some of you did
not its policy difference were you gonna
impeach President Obama because he did
not give them lethal aid no North sure
dove you you should not do that
it's policy difference policy difference
do not rise to the level of
constitutionally mandated or
constitutional applications for removal
from office it is policy differences
by the way it's not just on lethal
weapons then President Obama's I said
withheld aid he had the right to do that
you've allowed him to do that oh but we
don't like that this president did it so
the rules change
so this president's rules are different
than he he has a different set of
standards he has to apply than what you
allowed the previous administration to
apply and you know what or the future
administration comply that's the problem
with these articles we've laid out I
believe a compelling case on what the
Constitution requires when they were in
the House of Representatives putting
this together did they go through a
constitutionally mandated accommodations
process to see if there was a way to
come up with something no they did not
did they run to court
no and the one time it was about to
happen they ran the other way
separation powers mean something it's
not separation of powers and other
nonsense if we've reached now at this
very moment in the history of our
republic a bar of impeachment because
you don't like the president's policies
or you don't like the way he undertook
those policies because we heard a lot
about policies if partisan impeachment
is now the rule of the day which these
members and members of this Senate said
should never be the rule of the day my
goodness they said it some of them five
months ago
but then we had the national emergency a
phone call it's an emergency
except we'll look just wait but a
partisan impeachment based on policy
disagreements which is what this is and
personal presumptions or newspaper
reports and allegations in a unsourced
maybe this is in somebody's book who's
no longer at the White House and that
becomes the new norm future presidents
Democrats Republicans will be paralyzed
the moment they are elected before they
can even take the oath of office the bar
for impeachment cannot be set this low
Majority Leader McConnell Democratic
leader Schumer house managers members of
the Senate Danger Danger Danger these
articles must be rejected the
Constitution requires it
this demands it majority leader we would
ask for a short recess if we can about
15 minutes
the majority leader is recognized we'll
be in recess for 15 15 minutes without
objection
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]